thank you uh welcome everyone
so yeah my my name is Theo and I'm a
data scientist now moving to a
management
at get your guide and previously I was
also a machine learning engineer at
Twista and what I want to talk about is
software design python for data science
and what I want here in this talk is to
condensate what I've read and also
experienced and this is a kind of
subjective selection of thoughts that I
have
um yeah so that was originally
um
like will ask me to to to jump in for
these slots so the talk should be around
20 minutes and so we'll hope to have
some time for questions but yeah
I'm sorry I'm not as prepared as I wish
I would be I would like to so yeah
please bear with me
so with that let's start with the
introduction we'll Define what a design
button is and what is the focus on this
presentation then we'll dive into the
software design so more precisely like
what advice we want to give to a data
scientist that you should keep in mind
when designing software
then the second thing I want to dive
into are more ml designs and here I want
to talk more about choice in the
architecture that helps to have cleaner
data products or machine learning
products
and finally you conclude and open for
questions
so what is a design pattern so a design
pattern is a reusable solution to a
commonly occurring problem see it's not
a concrete piece of code that you can
just copy and paste from stack Overflow
what we want is actually to what help is
actually identifying the pattern will
help you first to understand the problem
that you are facing and also help
building a Common Language around this
problem
I do not want to focus this talk on
pattern how to improve your model
performance there are
already a lot of talks in the wild about
how you can improve accuracy and all
these kind of things here
what I want is pattern that can help you
bring your data product your model into
production and so basically push it
through the finance the finish line
okay let's dive first into our software
design pattern so here more like lower
lower level advice that IO can give so
the first thing that I think is
important to keep in mind is that you
should design after the fact so
in data science the work that we do is
closely related to research so there is
very high uncertainty around it so the
code that you will write tomorrow
depends on the result that you obtain at
the end of the day today
and so you should refactor to make it
right but do not try to over engineer
over engineer to what you think it will
be because you probably will be wrong so
you should make it right for what it is
today
um so you should keep it clean so that
you can understand it and just a
reminder what is refactoring it's the
process of reorganizing the code and
changing the without changing its
external Behavior
and
as like any software developer that's
part of the normal uh
software lifecycle to refactor the code
at it move forward basically and so
should keep in mind that this is part of
the job and you will have to refactor
your code as you do but just do it for
what is right for now
then the second thing is you should
design for people cognitive capabilities
so just as a reminder the we know that
we estimate that the humans can only
only holds around five elements in
memory so
that means that basically when you are
writing codes you should be able to
understand The Code by only
understanding five Concepts that means
breaking big function into pieces and
giving meaningful names so that people
do not have to remember what this a b i
j k Etc means
um so the goal is to keep these five
things so remember to understand and so
all the world is done it will struggle
also you will struggle in the future you
will struggle when you will try to read
your code
um it happened to me uh sure it already
happened to some of you
um
then
another one is designed for testability
and I think that's the most important
one mods most of what we do even in data
science can be tested and but we need to
design it accordingly
uh what we want in practice is to avoid
Legacy sorry Legacy code so Legacy code
what it is it's after that we are afraid
to modify because it might break in some
unexpected way
and I imagine all of you have already
experienced this that's
I don't know if I should touch that or
not
um yeah and test is something that helps
us to bring confidence when you want to
do any kind of change
and to give you a small a more a
practice an example in practice let's
imagine an example of a function that
was not designed without testability so
we we have some pre-processing steps
that are that is doing oh wait let me
can I put the point the laser yes so we
have a pre-processing thumb that is
doing some function uh and actually then
oh suddenly you need another table so
you just load this table then you join
and then you continue your your magic
here it's terrible to test what makes
much more sense is actually
to give them as of give these things
that you need as part of your function
so that if you need to test you can just
pass
different type of function is tend to
having to do some kind of mocking for
this table because it's hard coding in
the middle of the code
this as an example
of how you can basically make your code
designed for testability there are many
more things but I think that's the main
thing is like if you ask yourself how do
I want how can I test it that will help
you make the code in a much better shape
so yeah that's uh the three
main software patterns so first please
refactor your code this is part of the
process and it's normal to do it
you should break down the code into
pieces and five is a kind of rough
number you should try to keep in mind
and make it testable
so that you can test it the worst is a
piece of code that you cannot at least
not tested you need to you want to test
it but it's not designed to be testable
so you will need to refactor it before
you can test it but if you refactor it
without test you're already stuck
okay
so with that let's go into the ml
designs here what I want to talk more is
about architectural change that you can
do to be more effective in your code and
to have a cleaner data product at the
end
the first thing I want to talk about is
this workflow pipeline pattern so
usually a data science project or data
data product at the end is a composed of
multiple steps we have some
pre-processing we have done training we
then we need to deploy Etc and as a
project grows each steps grows and get
more and more complex
and so at some point you want to each of
them to be able to work on them
independently it might be not the same
at the same time not the same person or
never not the same team that work on
this different part
and so what you what you need is to have
some kind of controller being able to
containerize its of this step and to be
able to orchestrate them
see an example on the on the top of like
the different steps that you oh sorry
that you would expect so data collection
data validation pre-processing building
training evaluation and then you deploy
the model
um and as I say before you can have
different person doing different things
uh having this isolation make it more
possible and scalable and maintainable
there are some ml specific tool that
helps you like
tensorflow extended or ml flow pipeline
but actually you can also use some
tools that are not used specific for
machine learning like airflow they are
also pretty a really great like more
general purpose orchestration tool that
kind of help you do that
and once you have this workflow actually
um integrate then you can interact
integrate it in your Ci or also have
some kind of trigger to retrain
automatically and think that so it's it
helps you to be able to separate them so
that basically you can retrain
re-trigger some specific steps on some
specific events basically when I don't
know if you want maybe to retrain your
model once a week or if the the
production is getting oh it's something
is changing then it's good that you have
this things already
prepared basically
okay
then the second one really useful is
this transform design pattern
the the problem here is that the input
data usually is not the feature that we
will use for the model so there is some
kind of transformation that need to
happen to the to the input to be
transformed to our features and that
needs to happen for the training but
also for the in for the inference
and it easily can happen then we'll end
up with having two Logics one that you
have for the training and another one
for the inference and of course if you
have two pieces of code doing the same
thing
don't repeat yourself don't repeat
yourself
and you increase the chance of having
some kind of mismatch like the logic can
be slightly different and phosphorus
then you will end ups are some specific
weird things happening basically
and here this pattern is basically to
capture this transformation and keep
them and reuse them in both places
and just an example here is you can have
a model with an input that has some
inputs let's say the start date
basically and what you want is to
transform this feature into some example
like the feature will be a date of the
week or the how of the day and you would
like to do that you will need to do that
for training and inference this is the
kind of thing where this transform
pattern make lots of sense
this concept is already present in some
of the major Library uh like you have it
for example in pi spark with a
Transformer you have it in scikitlan
with this pipeline when you kind of have
the different transform and tensorflow
extended also have this concept
great
then last but not least the feature
store
so well the features of design pattern
the the goal here is to simplify the
management and the ReUse of the of the
features and what we want is to decouple
the feature creation from the model
development but just you should just use
it only if and only if the features that
are recreated are recreated that you
need for your model are recreated over
and over for different models and the
training and the serving features have
you already see that they have some
inconsistent and consistency
and finally
when you have
problemizing the features
so basically in the diagram I think it
will help understand what the features
are so basically it's a component that
you have between your data sources that
you're on one side and the models that
can have the that want to use these
features
and it will it's basically titled for ML
which make it easy to get some kind of
historical feature values
for the training or just get the latest
value that you have when you want to do
batch or online inference
there have been quite a lot of hype
around this concept and it
should use it wisely in sense that it
can add more complexity than it solves
so
you should be you should check with your
use case and use it only if it makes
sense for you
upgrades with that let's conclude
so yeah what's did today I wanted to
present some useful pattern that we had
for data science that I think you should
keep in mind when you design your your
project
um there are many more that were not
covered in this presentation
[Music]
and I just made my selection where I
think the top one
for me uh was the the most useful I hope
you find them useful but um yes finally
you might be able to identify some
pattern at some point but a decide not
to use it actually it's it's totally
fine just want to make sure like
actually just it identified its pattern
helped you to understand the trade-offs
that you are making if you want to use
it or not so best example will be again
what we had just before with this
feature store
and yeah I think I think it's we're
pretty nascent in data science there are
still not so much experience gathered
experience that we have as a whole so
this pattern are likely to evolve and
with the industry as uh
we've also yeah uh exciting time to see
it happening but that's that's the end
of my talk thank you very much
oh
I also put some references where these
things are coming from and I will share
the slide in the in the channel so that
you can also check this most of this
actually is coming from this excellent
boot machine learning design button but
also some blog posts that you can read
that are coming from
okay well thanks thanks Leo
um I'm not seeing any questions so far
in the slido
um so
getting quick
as meaningful names go I usually have
the problem that my names of my columns
explode and then you can't see anything
anymore do you have a golden rule for
balancing that one
um I mean
fasting
you have I mean usually the you have 80
characters for of all things and then
you have those four things characters
but still like if your name is more like
than 60 characters or something
that's pretty impressive
they're very expressive but then usually
naming things is one of the hardest
thing in computer science and yeah as
we're writing software in data science
and so we have the same problem but
usually when it happens the best thing
is actually to ask a colleague and
usually the colleague or like ask you
what artist is really doing and usually
you can shrink it and I now do not ask
that much my colleague I just ask myself
like explain what this is doing and
usually I come up with a shorter name
and there are some kind of recurrent
shotgun that you can use like with
respect to you can just do wrt and these
kind of things that you can use that are
repeated over and over so yeah that's my
common tip but in doubt I would prefer a
longer name that explode than having a
two-shot name that no one understands
thanks
I've just realized that I was meant to
be
approving uh slightly questions which is
why there's probably none in the chat
anyone anyone while I work out how to
fix that we've got time for me to fix
that but does anyone have a question
they want to ask over the microphone
um
cool yeah you'll keep a convenient
hi uh I'm not so much in this field but
I was wondering if you uh consider the
um you know the classic object-oriented
design patterns
that were described in the the gang of
four book that maybe a lot of people are
familiar uh how
um how relevant are those kinds of
design patterns
for data science and machine learning
in your opinion
I I think there are relevance I think
that's thing that's come on top of those
more than things and what I was thinking
about the software software one I think
the other
most basic one I as so for example
a true use object and things like that
yes it makes sense
but sometimes you can have clean code
with just some functions that if they
are well
designed and you have a meaningful name
it makes more sense to keep it easy and
not every data scientist or maybe a data
analyst that will run will understand
the intricate of some complex
pattern with some object oriented so
I think they are relevant
I still think that we have to adapt to
the audience that we have and not
everyone has a computer science
background in data science basically
thanks
okay so found some questions
um so there's a number of questions
about testing
and how much you test so like you know
given you know you're going to refactor
and the the I'm paraphrasing here but
given you're going to refactor what's
the
how do you make the decision between
writing tests now
and given that they're going to be
potentially obviously in the future
the Okay so
should you write a test if the test will
be obsolete soon basically
um so I think testing is important you
should have testing uh we ended up not
testing that much like with unit tests
in our pipeline but then I will commute
to the talk that I have in afternoon
where I say I will explain how we do
testing in data science
for the envelopes in practice the talk
of the afternoon the high level is
sometimes unit tests makes sense for
data science something most of the time
I think end-to-end tests make more sense
and there we use some real data to do
them
the thing is I think you should test
what you care for the most like if you
if you care that you're I don't know
that you are right on
on your Revenue that you generate or the
prediction or revenue and you want to
make sure that it cannot be negative or
thing like that it sounds a pretty good
use case like that's a very specific
Edge case if someone put a really weird
things on the on mobile input will that
give back some slightly wrong results
probably is not worth a test basically
so should be pragmatic when you test
cool okay so the top rated question is
is hard to prioritize refactoring over
working on new features any take on that
can you repeat this yeah it's hard to
prioritize refactoring over working on
new features and any take on that
yes it's hard
uh What uh what worked well in the uh
get your guide what we we have done and
I think we it can be introduced is
basically you plan in advance days where
you will focus on this Tech depth and
adding or adding tests and things like
that and you say like you can talk with
your PM your manager say like in the
team you want to have these two or three
days where we'll tackle the most
pressing Tech Lab things that we have
and it will be in one month something
like that and then on these days you
will be only be able to focus on this uh
topic and that's a good the best way we
found to be able to tackle this I know
that if you follow the normal devops
let's say that every Sprint you should
be adding some 10 to 15 or sorry uh 20
of the your time to work on this but it
did not work well for me for us we
always end up spending most of our time
on the project and never on this ticket
that we're over pushback so but this
thing of like we blocked days and these
days are not for project time they are
for Tech depth uh testing and things
like that
and of course the other things is
once it happened it's too late but at
least you can make sure it won't happen
again so once you have an incident
that's something very wrong happen I
usually people are much more
comprehensive why you want to add a test
to make sure it won't happen again
yeah
um okay so the next uh Next Top question
is do you have any tips on how to
organize the code like the you know your
code base based on these design patterns
oof
no it depends on the project the size of
the project I think like if you are just
have some
some scripts then probably you should
introduce some function if you have a
lot of functions probably should
introduce some classes probably some
repetition that happen so I think the
project will go with time I think there
are some great
templates with cookie cutter that you
can use to how you want to organize
between the test and the project and
things like that
um
I will say please keep the the bare
minimum like first put it in our
repository that will be the first first
thing and please have put the test in
another repository then in another
folder then the thing that you had your
code
make some documentation
so I'll have some something for for
readme that people can understand
um but then as it evolved I think it
does not make sense to I will refer back
to the first like design for what you
have now if you even if you think that
this project will be an amazing thing
and you should have it will have
thousand line of calls but right now
it's just hundreds just write the code
that is like make the the repository
work for her 100th line of code things
not have 20 repository with everything
uh just 10 line of codes because you
expect that to be expanded just refactor
as we as you go and make it right for
what it is now
cool
um next question is are those real
software design patterns or best
practice from get your guide
um and then no offense I like them a lot
and follow similar rules that's what the
person said but basically these are
these actual design patterns that you're
using in your work
it was a really good question
um
yes uh yes and no I mean like they are
coming from my personal experience so I
do not represent get your guide in this
in this presentation
but uh yes for example we have a feature
store that we we are experimenting with
[Music]
um
we
we also try to keep the code like I will
not say we are perfect actually there
was this presentation started as an
internal one we say hey this is where we
should be going internally in our data
product team
um so
and where where I think we we need to we
need to improve so uh yeah that's we are
working on it
okay cool uh so the next two questions
are both about feature stores so I'm
just going to kind of merge them
together
um so well once it's a longer version
the other so can you elaborate a bit
more about feature Stores
um and then maybe some experiences
um and how they look like
um yeah they're quite popular at the
moment so uh can you dig into feature
stores
um I mean
um I also had watched you use a feature
store and there is also some nice
diagram here but uh can I make it a bit
bigger
basically is
um how when should you use a feature
store or not basically that was also
coming from this blog post uh I think
the most important things is like
feature stock can be really helpful to
you if it takes the right boxes this is
like you have some your feature that you
repeat over and over you uh you have
struggled to productionizing them and
you have problems uh I think Morena I
see in the audience here I did a talk on
feature store on the pi data Meetup some
time ago and uh
yeah they are a big beast basically so
use them if you have a big problem
that would be my my main point
um
they are they are made for machine
learning and that can solve a big
problem so which you can have which make
sure that you have the training
um so I think it will refer to this one
that when you train you are sure to have
the right data for the right time in
point like you always have this problem
of leakage data leakage basically where
you can for example if you train a model
and you look at what are the booking
each customer's did before to try to
predict you have to make sure that the
booking you try to predict is not in the
future of the user when you look at some
aggregation on this and this is tricky
to do and feature store can help you
solve this kind of problem
very easily but
you should have this problem basically
and also make sure to have always the
last value when you do online inference
basically
okay so that you've also answered the
other one of the other questions which
was what are the disadvantages okay so
you've got nothing more to add on that
cool
um
we've got time for maybe one more quick
question what are the advantages and
disadvantages of using tools like ml
flow over building the pipelines
manually for example using kubernetes
job or Jenkins or whatever right like
what's the what are the advantages and
disadvantages of using tools like ml
flow over building pipelines manually
um
less you build less you have to maintain
don't forget that
and the nice thing with this tools is
that people like a lot of people are
working in to improve them so it's just
like I introduced that and as we move
forwards things are getting better
basically whereas if you do it yourself
well everything you build you have to
maintain and if you don't touch it it
will not get better basically so there
are I think that's the main trade-off
and I we are at get together we're
really biased toward open source uh
because we think it's
it's really great to be able to reuse
these tools when they mix when they make
sense not sometimes you have to build it
because we cannot find a tool that
solved this problem and then we build it
but most of the time they are tools that
exist and then we have we can help
contribute basically or if we don't then
we have a specific problem then we make
a tool and then we open source it
awesome uh well that's us that's time so
uh I think another round of applause for
Theo